Okay let's take a look at the answers to
these questions. So for the first aid kit question,
there are actually 2 bands named first aid kit
one of them being in Sweden and I forget actually
where the other one is from. What's the begin
area name for queen? This is actually a pretty easy
one. It is London. Okay? The Spanish alias for
Beatles. This happens to be Los Beatles. There's actually a
BBC recording where they talk about the Spanish alias for the Beatles. It's an
interview with John, Paul, George and Ringo.
Okay, enough Beatles nerdery. Alright, the Nirvana Disambiguation.
So there are actually a few bands named Nirvana. The Kurt Cobain Nirvana is
disambiguated in music brains with the label,
"90s US Grunge Band." Okay? And when was
One Direction formed? 2010.